and when we make these choices i think
just as important
if not more important is the story that
we are telling ourselves about
why we made the choices and what that
tells us about who we are
[Music]
what's going on everyone i want to tell
you a story that may be applicable to
you if you're
an existing entrepreneur a new
entrepreneur or someone who's about to
make a big decision in life
uh yesterday uh i had a conversation
that transpired between me and an 18
year old
who's now a freshman in college and
i think there i wish i could have
recorded it but there were a lot of kind
of
decision points and lessons and thought
processes that we walk through together
that i think will be valuable for for
many because it's the same
it's honestly the same decision-making
process whether you're making a
multi-million dollar decision or you're
making a
you know relationship decision or
whatever it is and so
um this 18 year old kid is uh my
neighbor i think i've referenced them
before
and he's entrepreneurial he did a little
car washing business he's done a little
uh e-commerce business that he started
on his own and and it's and it's worked
out you know pretty decently well for
him
but because of the pressures that he's
had on himself and from outside he
decided he had to do college
and so he started his first semester in
college and to make a long story short
he did something he wasn't supposed to
do and now he's in trouble and that may
jeopardize his
future in college and so he's obviously
really wrecked about this
and so i i said hey let's go for a walk
and so
on this walk i said you know what's
what's your plan he's well i think i'm i
you know i think i'm gonna try and fight
this thing um
and you know give college another shot
and um i
i wanted to walk him through this
because i wanted him to make
any decision for the right reasons right
and so i said
you know do you think like what do you
what's the outcome
you want to have from giving another
shot at college right because he didn't
really like high school that much
he's like well you know i just want to i
want to give it a try
i was like okay again what do you want
to have happen or what do you think is
going to happen
what is the positive outcome that you're
potentially looking forward to the
negative outcome that you think could
happen
he's like well
honestly i don't know and i was like
okay now we're getting somewhere
so do you think that taking you know
genders literature studies and history
of aztec culture
whatever is going to be more interesting
to you now
than the stuff that you studied in high
school which was again general
literature is that going to be
interesting to you it's like
well probably not i was like okay then
what's the real reason that you want to
go
to college it's like well you know i
feel like i you know i'm a kid and i
should experience
you know having fun and all that kind of
stuff and i was like okay
having fun's fine do you feel like you
can
have fun without going to college do you
think that you could
not spend two hundred thousand dollars
in four years of your life and still
have fun in that same period of time if
you weren't at college
but still with other people who are your
age i was like well yeah i guess so i
was like okay
cool then i'm assuming that's not the
only reason you want to go to college
what else is there he started thinking
he's like honestly
i don't really know and so
to give you a little bit more context
before what i told him next
i asked him what do you think because
he's doing his entrepreneurs he's
starting a new entrepreneur
thing right now with real estate and he
hasn't he hasn't cracked it yet
right and so i said do you think it's
possible
that you want to go to college because
it's in a
it's a it's a socially acceptable shield
for you not being successful in
entrepreneurship
do you think do you think that that
might be a reason because if you're in
college
then you you're not seen as a failure if
you're
not winning at the thing that you're
doing right it's your side hustle it's
your side gig
he's like well maybe yeah and
i think first off you know kudos to him
for being able to realize and admit that
but i think that that
was is such a core issue for many of us
is that we present these socially
acceptable solutions to ourselves
when deep down the reason that we're
doing them is not for the right reason
and so in this instance he's using it as
a foil to protect himself
against having to confront the realities
of life of business of the marketplace
of not being good enough right yet
and so i said all right well what do you
want to have happen in your life
do you think you want to have a job and
he was like no i don't want to have a
job
like what do you want to do he's like i
want to have my own business and i was
like
what do you think business school looks
like in the real world he was like well
probably
doing business i was like okay so if you
have four years
and two hundred thousand dollars if you
invest that in college
versus investing two hundred thousand
dollars in four years into
learning into trying to start your own
business which of them after four years
do you think will get you closer to your
goal
he was like well probably the business
one i was like okay
so then right now what you have is a
clear logical
logical outcome in terms of which
decision path to make
but then now we have to start looking at
what's the emotional driver that's
preventing you from doing it
right and so for him
going all in means making the first real
trade-off he's ever made in life
right because if you're newer or you
have a job or you're you know
it doesn't matter where you're at in
your life there a lot of times
especially when we're younger there's
there's fewer big branch points
right but as we get older we have to
commit
and trade off something else right it's
this for that
and i think excuse me sorry um
i think that a lot of times we have to
frame these things in terms of the
things that we're willing to sacrifice
and so i told him the story of uh
when i was starting my gym the mindset
that i approached it with was
i will not outwork everyone but instead
i will out sacrifice anyone and so what
i meant
by that is i'm willing to put everything
and anything that i have
on the altar of my success and that's
what i started from a mindset standpoint
so i wasn't like
i'm gonna be smarter or i'm gonna do
something else i just knew that anytime
my competitors or other people were
going out
or they were you know seeing friends or
playing video games or watching football
games which i used to do all the time
before i started a business
or or sleeping in or just all the many
things you know even honestly my fitness
even suffered during that period of time
i'm not saying it's perfect but i'm
saying i was willing to do
i was willing to sacrifice anything to
get to where i wanted to go and i
introduced that kind of concept to him
of like
you tell me you want these things
and yet when it comes time to sacrifice
to pay the piper to make the trade-offs
that are that are necessary to have that
outcome
that's when you're faltering and so
do you are you willing to sacrifice for
the things that you want in the long run
i was like because he's my neighbor and
we live in a nice neighborhood
i said like i'm the age i am and we live
here i was like i sacrificed my 20s
straight up i sacrifice them and i'm not
saying it's the right path
but i want to make sure that whatever
decision you make
you make it for the right reasons if you
want to go for four years in college
do it by all means but understand the
reason you're doing it
is because you believe that four years
of college and spending 200 000
is the best use of your time and then
having the story that you'll have to
tell yourself
about the type of person who makes these
types of decisions
and then you'll have to live with that
because the thing is is the stories that
we tell ourselves
create the identity that we that we have
right my favorite scenes in
the matrix is in the third one i know
people don't like the second and third i
like all three
um is when morpheus is standing in front
of all of humanity
and he says i can tell you that i
stand here truthfully unafraid not
because
of the path that lies before us but
because of the path that lies behind me
and i think that's such a such a such a
deep
message because where we are is because
of the stories that we have that have
led us to
be who we've become and when we make
these choices
i think just as important if not more
important is the story that we are
telling ourselves about
why we made the choices and what that
tells us about who we are
and so i wanted to clarify the decision
for him in terms of is this what you
want yes or no
of these two paths which one will get
you closer to that thing
yes like this one or this one cool now
why are you not making it which now goes
from logic to emotion
and then at that point saying okay i
think we've discovered the root issue
which is that you're afraid is being
seen as a failure if you're not
immediately successful
and so what i wanted to give to him was
if you fail it does not make you a
failure it means that you failed
and part of entrepreneurship is failure
and being able to deal with failure
and how you come back from failure and i
said right now you're in this instance
where this is the first real big hit
life has ever given you
right everything's relative but in his
life at this moment this is the biggest
thing worst thing that's ever happened
right this bad issue that he had with
his school
and so i said the story that you now get
to tell is what you do from here
right do you use this as the catalyst to
realize that
you actually don't aren't interested in
the school stuff and you never have been
and have always wanted to do the
entrepreneur thing but it's been a side
hustle and you've never fully committed
to it
i was like is that is that the story you
want to tell
or do you want to go and try and fight
this thing and try and beat it and then
spend you know another three and a half
years spending more money
and then be another 3.1 student that
graduates from pepperdine
right which one is the story that you
want to tell
and so i think i wanted to share this
story with you because i don't know
where you're at
or what decisions you're facing but i
think there was a lot of
many things that we kind of covered in
that conversation and unearthed
and so many of us know what we need to
do but have some emotional trigger
that's stopping us from doing it
and i think digging deep and saying like
what am i afraid of happening
what's my biggest fear because if i know
this is what i need to do then why am i
not doing it
and i think if you can simply name the
fear of what you are afraid of it allows
you to face it and it removes the power
it has over you
because then you you have clarity and
then it's simply
am i willing to let my fear of failure
stop me from having what i want to
eventually have in my life
or would i rather let that have me walk
down a path that never actually helps me
realize my potential
and so when you think about a maybe
versus a never
then i'll take a maybe over and never
any day of the week
and so like i said i don't know where
you're at i don't know what trade-offs
are facing i don't know what sacrifices
you may have to make in order to get to
where you want to go
um but i think literally listing those
things out of what you are willing to
give up
there was a point in my life where i i
wrote down all the things that i had to
additionally give up because i was at a
point of just rubber meeting the road
and i had to push harder
and this was probably three or four
years into my entrepreneurial journey
and i remember making this video about
that where
i i actively gave up football on sundays
which was like a thing that i enjoyed
you know watching um i know that i gave
up all tv
of all kinds even like the wind down tv
i gave up any kind of going out
and i'm not saying that you have to do
that i'm just saying that that's what i
did
and i know that this kid's father was
like hey you need to have balance
you need to you need to be able to enjoy
life you're still young and
my father when i was younger really hit
on
that really hard and i really pushed
back and i still
pretty much do because i don't believe
that anything great was ever
accomplished by someone who is balanced
i think that it takes extremes it takes
extreme effort it takes unreasonable
sacrifice in order to achieve things
that are unreasonable
and so you know and i was telling him
yesterday
the kid not my dad if
you were competing against someone else
who was a coder you guys are both coding
software right
i was like and you're going to college
you're having fun you're going out on
weekends and
you know you code a couple hours a day
versus
the kid who drops out of college codes
16 hours a day
doesn't go out doesn't see his friends
just codes
for three and a half years it's like who
do you think will be further along he
was like well the other kid
and i was like right like how much
further along he was like probably a lot
further
i was like right do you think it's
reasonable or unreasonable that he would
be further ahead than you
it's like reasonable and i was like so
why would you not want to take the
reasonable bet
that you will be so much further ahead
by making that choice
and so all that to say i don't know any
people who are really successful
who don't approach things in an
unbalanced way and i think that there's
a differentiation between
seasons and your entire life what you do
for a season of life doesn't have to be
forever
but sometimes it does have to be for
that season and sometimes you are
uneven and so sometimes it's difficult
to look you know at what i do now
versus what i did to get here right if i
you know
i sacrificed my fitness for periods of
time
right i'm not saying it was good i'm
just saying i did um
there were times where i did not sleep
as much as i probably should have
uh there were times where i did not see
i didn't do anything social at all four
months
i'm not saying it was right i'm just
saying that's what ended up happening
and when i hear stories of many people
who kind of go through the [ __ ]
who go through their rocky balboa period
uh the rocky cut scene
almost every hyper-successful person
that i've seen
goes through a three to five year period
where they just get hit in the face day
after day after day after day
you know some of the some of the great
marketers some of you guys may have
heard of you know russell brunson
pitched for five straight years on
stages
unknown before he became russell brunson
you know billie jean did cold calling
for two three years
dan kennedy did face to face
door-to-door sales for three years
right i did four thousand one-on-one
consultations over a four-year period
selling fitness doing 15 20 appointments
a day right
and the thing is is like i wasn't alex
ramosey then i was just a dude who was
selling
and just getting better and better and
the thing is that there's this
unreasonable amount of effort this
unreasonable amount of sacrifice that
usually has to go in
to get the unreasonable goal and yet
people are not willing to make the
sacrifice to do
it and so i think if we can simply look
at what is the decision that's going to
get me to where i want to go
which of these do i think will be better
and then what is the sacrifice that's
required and am i willing to make that
sacrifice
then i think it makes much simpler
decisions
and we know why we're making the
decisions we are so that the decisions
are not made for us by life
so anyways i hope that was valuable for
you um it was just top of mind because i
had the conversation yesterday and i
thought
man i wish i had recorded this um but i
don't know where you're at in your life
and i don't know what decisions you're
facing but
hopefully this provides value for you so
lots of love keeping amazing and i'll
catch you next vid
bye
[Music]
[Applause]
you